I'm gonna give you the two scriptures
that changed my entire life
oh hell no no no no no like you just
decided and you said yourself you know
what how can I kiss off preach today I'm
gonna tell you the two things he doesn't
like and put them together scriptures
and [ __ ] Steve Harvey and then you
know what let me put a third thing in
there that really appreciates eggs Steve
Harvey look like a big inning let me
give you my two best pictures ah
you sicken me the first scripture you
have not because you ask not now listen
to me a lot of the problems I was having
and you may be having just like me is
because what I was asking God for was
the wrong stuff I kept going to him too
small you might be one of the dumbest
things that uh bro you don't need a
Honda Civic we're good pray for a
Maserati you have not because you ask
not you have not been pushed in the face
yet but it's coming Lord help me make my
rent
well don't he always don't you always
get your it so how'd you end up here
I just couldn't afford to pay for an
apartment at this time so that's how I
became what about if you change that
suppose you saying lord help me make my
mortgage I was just joking about the
Maserati thing actually serious how
about you pray for a castle
how about you pray for a space shuttle
you have not as children are dying every
day from hunger and sickness these
children are facing death right now but
with your support in just 50 cents a day
we can save them you have not you should
have been praying for a buffet for the
rest of eternity little boom boom
now starve to death yeah God don't give
you what you want
he gave you what you believe mm-hmm you
know I feel like though it's cause of
the way he says things you sound smarter
than is God give you what you want I
have a dream Jesus Jesus sometimes
you're walking you walk him in the park
with silver in hand you asked a no ask
yourself you know who's holding me I
don't know what Jesus is his name God
the Father Mary - mom Joseph the cook
Jesus man it's this kind of like you
want me and it makes no sense but it
sounds phonetically nice so you're
thinking man this man is wise when
really there's just a snake oil salesman
see you've been floored if you up your
ask he ups his guild that's his promise
you have not because you ask not
lord help me fix my car so I can make it
to work stop praying Oh
these raggedy cars why don't you ask God
for a car that don't need fixing oh you
think that's too big for him is that it
so you don't ask this great God for big
stuff because you don't see how you can
get it you're not supposed to see how
you can get it you're just supposed to
asking for it see the how-to is none of
your business you keep getting in the
way of a blessing because you all up in
how to part of it
show me the scripture where he tells you
to figure out how to do anything
listen you show me another video like
that I'll punch you in the mouth what
the [ __ ] is this the reason why these
videos haven't stopped kiss you ask not
[Laughter]
shall we stop this YouTube can we stop
internet can we stop the world can we
stop the revolution of the earth around
the Sun can we stop the universe can we
stop time is that they enough I don't
know the Godfather secondly you don't
have it written down everything you're
asking God for it has to be written down
Jesus Jesus I've just eaten in for five
days I I wish very Buffy hey little
[ __ ] have you written it down alright
Jesus I don't have arm strength peace
that because I didn't write something
down he wouldn't answer my prayer and
because I didn't ask my [ __ ] higher
where they're supposed to be he would
not answer it Jesus really operates in
the waist Steve claims then I said god I
don't want to believe it oh I just
refused to believe that the mystical
figure of Jesus a man of the cloth
person who needed very little but
sandals in a rope to get around town
now he wouldn't demand that we asked for
the high Sun highs of prayers in order
to get by through life I just think it's
very very paradoxical to the kind of
ideas that his symbolism meant you know
rich people don't really have
Bill Gates and Mark Zuckerberg they got
a degree between new but they got Moe
degrees working for them then at the
momma doe education ain't in the Bible
Harvard is not in there whoa-kay
less educated people tend to be far more
god-fearing and that's just a fact so of
course it's in the self-interest to tell
you that education is not in the Bible
and and the other person he named a lot
of other very rich people do have
degrees that's not to see the degrees
today aren't less than other than they
were before but this idea this hippie
dippie ideas that you don't need [ __ ]
and you just make it for some people it
is necessary good luck being that
doctors out of god damn degree know what
should you be educated yes whether it
comes at a university or your own self
response work they should always be
educated you should always be learning
and expanding your mind in regards to
these kind of things because the smarter
we come the better informed choices that
we can make for the future and our
children I mean that's it for me with
the Steve Harvey [ __ ] I can't listen to
him you know I mean and follow your
viewers out there who want us to stop
playing his videos we haven't stopped
because you didn't ask you have not
because you ask not
yeah maybe you should have written it
down maybe it would have limit so write
a comment you have not because you
didn't subscribe so subscribe
[Music]
[Applause]